e aí galera que aceite meu canal do boi
com você e hoje eu tô aqui pra falar
ainda assim ainda dança todo mundo na
rua talim dancinha não vai faltar lançou
o desafio então se esse vídeo que bater
3 milhões de likes próximo vídeo tendo
assim o jato que gostei aí que eu vou
ficar de animado já cara vocês têm mão
eu tenho um irmão pra entretenimento em
casa é isso né meu irmão ea relação de
amor e ódio carga horário de verão tem
hora que você gosta de hora você acha
muito necessário termos eu tenho dois
irmãos ea irmã a idéia inicial do meu
pai da minha mãe ela tem uma menina só e
acabou encerrada a atividade só que aí
nasceu meu irmão depois nasceu o meu
outro irmão e por nasceu e depois na seu
irmão ou seja é todo todos nós crescemos
nesse ambiente lindo e maravilhoso
sabendo que todos nós fomos indesejada a
meu filho te amo tanto cara e nem era
para ser mas eu tinha um irmão você tem
mais velho você tem maluco você o irmão
mais velho vai ter um encosto na sua
vida que bom se você fosse nascer levar
o diabo essa criança acho que é por isso
que os pais sentem mais de um filme
especial senão vou ter um filho aqui e
vou mandar ele leva a outro fator lugar
para me livrar dessas pragas meu deu ea
qualquer lugar mas vou jogar bola e
levar seu irmão o mães em mim entrava
todo lugar que eu vou é sim uma roupa
fecha edson o cabaré google é seu irmão
também não deixa ele vê preto lá no
camarim não é triste que a tua vida vira
simplesmente você cuidar do seu irmão
para não morrer é só isso é basicamente
isso cuido eu morrer só estava o irmão
mas não só a renda de casa água verde
saindo começa em comprar o negócio fala
vai só não morre por favor não morre só
ele sabe que tem que aguentar de quando
era criança tururu umirim agora tem uma
look to you
a fico indignado fala muito da área
pegando assim um salgadinho é isso que
acontece é uma instituição mais novo é o
encosto da vida de outra pessoa por quem
eu jogo vira porque por onde ele vai te
levar o lugar com o irmão mais velho vai
é muito mais massa do que um lugar que
tu vai quanto é crível e montillo o
roger dos amigos dele estão bebendo e
também o bebê e e aos amigos do irmão
mais febre tons peitão falar em teu
irmão é o mais novo harry somar vem
cuida de mim gente alguém que cuida de
mim agora com a inevitável entrei na
briga e não briga por tudo e não briga
por qualquer coisa principalmente por
nada nada nada briga começa obrigado na
por exemplo a atenção terminou tudo o
que ele vê fei para discutir hoje está
passando sbt eu lembro você hoje
corcunda de notre dame eu tranquilo
caminha na sala eu estou na televisão eu
corri quando eu fui ver o caminho
eu comecei a mãe então olha com um toque
no norte do am
o rapaz que não conheço de ficar
brigando com meu irmão não é a mãe
começa a botar qualidade na coisa feia
que seu irmão falou que parecia parecia
amenizar a situação não ficou com o
norte da agulha coconote dando trabalha
ganha dinheiro ele toca o sino da igreja
o fmi é forte um poste forte aí fiquei
mais triste ainda que ela não falou que
eu não parecer um pouco na guitarra
a briga mais engraçado se envolver na
vida que você é dois irmãos a ver quem
vai usar o banheiro está entrando no
banheiro ele não tava já havia ingerido
sabe gerir não eu já tô aí já não vai a
tempo voltou a atuar junto com o tom é o
que tem a ver eu já tô atoa e não foi só
o cágado tomar banho rapaz vai tomar
banho já do vitória já não cabe gerir
mal o carro fosse meia adam foi no carro
rápido time chegou a sair já atrasado
jogador muito começa a ganhar embora a
morada do banheiro bem né
olha eu fiquei avaria a casa não impor o
voto é para chocar garrafa
mas não sinto raiva vai parar em outra
briga vai acontecer direto porque sempre
um trabalho mais do que o outro não
adianta alguém vai trabalhar mais do que
alguém soubesse a carroça tabu barbachan
we will i am world dececa louça tão
grande ou raiva toda a raiva é preciso
lavar
eu prefiro lava e dignos e limpa se lá
com aquela cor bonita secar ninguém pede
paz e cafés sacá-los não é caiu que lhe
restou assim venceu boston está a fazer
nada pelo meio e chutou o escopo
combinando só quem tem um irmão veste
roupa comida da mãe comprar um terceiro
foi a roupa a todos os filhos um todo
igual para essa boneca horas a mulher
que o povo mandou nautique teclas roupa
tudo igual é meu irmão era maior que eu
quando eu crescia e usava roupa dele
pode ser que usava a mesma roupa vida
inteira só mudavam de tamanho a roupa do
corpo ficava puto e me tirar do sério
era quando me mexendo minhas coisas às
vezes ela parecia boa que era minha irmã
era uma coisa que estava sem largar em
cima da mesa não sei que dá pra pegar e
usar não era um coaching escondido assim
ou seja ela funcionou procurou mexer na
minha escolha foi solta e solta dizendo
que só chegava a mãe é não é não estava
só brincando é só brincar
ae só que era uma nova não apoiava em
quem ela batia em mim
ae era ela que tinha mexido as minhas
coisas que nunca apoiei a briga desse
jeito mais chega perto acabou para o
irmão briga por querer menino tinha vai
lutar em voltava à noite e amanhã pode
brincar de luta que lhe causa vai dar
certo é e só que se começa a brincadeira
aí com força e só come só e só e só deve
aguentar agora vens não aguento já tá
com um brincadeira de briga é não é a
brincar com o irmão só quem fala mal do
irmão ou a gente é a gente gosta dos
estados unidos fala do brasil a copa do
brasil nós acabamos casa é violência não
tem mais segurança a educação está ruim
ninguém consegue por dia o brasil é um
escaravelho pato falou é realmente o
brasil tem lixo uma guerra ainda que a
pasta vai cuidar do teu país e seu povo
o brasil tá um lixo o respeito brasil
começa igual tamanho mas botaram as
qualidade para ver se levanta o brasil
um pouquinho a prometer em massa e
neymar não tem neymar então manter o
punho não tiver neymar falou comigo o
povo aprender chantagear os outros que
só quem não sabe a tarde é filho único
não é preparar para a vida para poder
fazer uma chantagem à pessoa dele de
criança aprende evento chegou de
madrugada escondido o fast fórum fostes
para frente das mãos e já vão usar
aquele contra você tem uma pessoa para
realizar suas metas junto embora subia
igual homem aranha embora ele foi embora
mas o primeiro ato vai com ele cai e
quebra o braço que a ideia era boa
execução aquino foi o governo acaba
muito fazer memória aquilo que a criança
tem a mão certinha e os pés de pato e
agora quero chegar lá em cima e tal de
maipú na batalha no joelho e sai sangue
a ideia era boa execução não foi bom
nunca prepara um trampolim em baixo um
bom colchão e jackson e jônatas obina
o ita como é de se conferir seu sim
aprendi que você deve confiar nas
pessoas com seu irmão se vai falar agora
pedir à mãe paranaense joga bola bom
jogar lá mora eu eu bato fala com elas
porque tu só bate eu não falar o que tem
alguém para matar a fome assim o bem
barata e fácil não deixa que eu mato em
conversa com ela na justiça aí você não
é um cara bateu feito acho que é fácil é
bater na porta fácil né falou assim todo
mundo bate qualquer pessoa para o cotão
cotoco batalha porque vai com um toque
assim button vai me bater na porta eu
falo com ela tá bom a gente ia chegava
lá ele batia ocorrido à mãe saia godê
monte a
a mãe deixou ai ai ai pedindo confiar em
todo mundo eu gostava não usar de
exemplo o meu sobrinho não fala aí o
ibson estuda falar é é um estudo por
exemplo só que ela começa a me acabar na
frente ela falar nada mas estudos
envolvendo é fé é mais estuda uma praga
dessa nação diz ele porque vai pedir à
mãe tô errado todo topo mas estuda a mãe
para tá bom estudo todo mundo merece nem
se formou em direito todo errado arrumar
ou enfim meu deus há de tudo era só com
o meu irmão ficar tirando um ano passar
meia rodrigo jumento pela rua otto o
jumento e viemos mais 11 ilo minha mãe
rapaz lá senão meu momento é forte chuva
em jumento você pisar no disco y la
longe ele grita e festa de arromba
grande jumento é difícil eu queria saber
como é ter gêmeos a que foi a primeira
pessoa que viu o gênio quando nasceu foi
feita aparelhos caiu 21 mil do céu me
xingar é isso o mec gêmeos se xinga
sichem o gêmeo idêntico existindo porque
é igual à que se você se xingar você
xinga a ele também chega o cara falou
assim ah pai eu sou feio eo outro
responde não sofrer o que eu sei o que
eu devo ser agora por lá e tomar no meu
cubatão anel com um lance tomorrow dar
um tapa na minha casa ou dar um tapa
indústria fome é de fome há até do
próprio bb fato venha agora a ultimar
solta solta no meio comparou para ocupar
o edifício irmão você gostou desse vídeo
clique gostei compartilha ele marca do
irmão tinham seu irmão chama sua mãe é
aceite esse vídeo junto eu quero ser o
momento aqui embaixo vai ter que se acha
mais difícil de ter um irmão e o que
você acha mais legal que tem um irmão
meu bebê tem o próximo vídeo é nóis e
brooke e valeu